the ingram angle has exclusively
obtained leaked footage from a
department of labor panel about
transgenderism fox's own matt finn is in
our west coast newsroom with all of the
alarming details matt
hi laura the video was obtained by a
congressional source and shows trans
activists speaking at a department of
labor webinar about how to provide safe
and nurturing spaces for trans employees
one of the activists with the pronoun
she her and goddess told attendees that
some white men don't acknowledge trans
identities and want to criminalize trans
people
that's what we're dealing with is like
really reclaiming all those identities
that have always existed
right but because of colonization
and um
those cis white men not understanding
and being confused about what they saw
like well you're either male or female
that's it
another trans activist said that if
insurance companies will not lower
copayments for gender reassignment
surgeries then she might go back to sex
work to pay for it
if i go get an elective surgery or top
or bottom surgery and my co-payment is
four and five eight thousand dollars i
might as well go pay for the surgery
myself and back out here sex working if
that's the case
republican congressman matt gates sent a
letter to the labor secretary martin
walsh on monday requesting more
information about the webinar and asking
walls to investigate writing in part the
conversation is entirely inappropriate
and the claims made are without any
merit it is shocking that dol employees
are using their time at work to have an
open-ended partisan forum consisting of
abrasive social commentary we have
reached out to the labor department for
response but so far have not heard back
just yet laura matt thank you and
joining me now is the aforementioned
florida congressman matt gates who got
his hands on this video congressman now
what does any of this
have to do
with furthering the mission of the
department what am i missing here
well what's bizarre is that in the name
of inclusion our government is embracing
the policies of exclusion and it's
really state-sponsored racism for your
money to be used by the department of
labor to try to say that all of
society's flaws are the fault of white
men so i believe we have to expose these
things when they happen i believe when
we retake the house we have to actually
use the power of the purse to stop this
and then when we retake the white house
we have to reorient these agencies where
they actually work for people's freedoms
i mean if the department of labor is
going to be focused on pronouns instead
of the freedom of people to actually
work in our country why even have a
department of labor well good i think
that's a great question that's that's
what we should do is get rid of the
whole department now i want to play
another clip from this panel
for a long time i had this trans
identity right that did not allow me to
to center my femininity and i i often
walk that line of being looking
androgynous yeah i have allowed myself
to
go completely into what i like to call
my goddess mode i'm both male and female
um i you know i am just energy
i am energy
uh congressman
again the
the purpose of the labor department i
mean i shouldn't laugh this is actually
serious
someone's paying for this somewhere
along the line i imagine
maybe they do this for free around the
country but i doubt it because a lot of
these people get paid big money to be
consultants in this arena speaking of
the goddesses and centering femininity
and all these important labor department
topics for birthing people i'm
i'm going to find out exactly how much
this cost because we may see a
circumstance under divided government
where we have to shut down the
government in order to get what we need
to secure the border or to dewokify
these agencies and if it comes to that i
at least want the american people to see
the government that we are shutting down
literally people focusing more on
pronouns than people and whether or not
one has gone into goddess mode
effectively probably doesn't inform on
whether or not they are an effective
worker in our society and are in our
economy i remember the trump economy
where we had rising wages and success
and actual labor that was prosperous now
under joe biden we just have a weird
labor department that seems like a bad
trade now matt at some point i think the
republicans
more than just you and a few others
saying this actually have to start
saying we're not spending any more money
on this i mean we're not i mean right
now we could do that with the us
military but there are too many
establishment go peers who would never
touch a dime of military spending but
this is happening across every agency
that it's one of the reasons why we're
not recruiting
up to the goals that we need for each
branch of the military as we just
discussed so this has got to be funded
across the board
i do think we're going to have to
bifurcate our analysis there will be
some agencies like the department of
defense that we have to keep around and
they will have to be de-occupied but
there may be other agencies where the
rot is so deep like at the department of
education or the department of labor or
at the epa where we really can't salvage
a meaningful government mission for our
people and the question is whether or
not the republicans will endeavor to
fight on that and to expose it and to
actually use the power of the purse you
know our friend ran paula's is saying
when the democrats are in power the
republicans are the conservative party
and when the republicans are in power
there is no conservative party that's
why these primaries you're reporting on
tonight are so important because we need
the backup to have a spine to stop this
to shut it down and actually make our
government work for our people yeah the
establishment keeps failing we don't
want to reelect them congressman thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else